i've gotten several nicknames
one of the biggest ones that stick out
in my mind was one run anderson
i would run one time but i'm gonna tell
you right now you better have your
cameras ready because it was going to be
one big bad run
i'm dennis anderson and i'm the original
gravedigger
if you don't know what a monster truck
is it's because you're a concrete
cruising city slicker the definition of
a monster truck is it has to have a 66
43 tera tire meaning 66 inches tall
43 inches wide and normally they're
around 10 to 12 foot tall
and 12 foot wide and they usually weigh
about 10 to 12 000 pounds that's what a
monster truck is
my goal in life as a kid growing up is i
wanted to be this big farmer it never
really was a goal in life for me to be
a pro monster jam truck driver
dennis anderson and the gravedigger
the whole legacy of gravedigger this
right here was the first stepping stone
my goal in life as i was building this
truck was to have a big nice shop with a
concrete floor because i built this
thing in a tin chicken house
i call it my empire and it's the
gravedigger empire here
now we're up to nine gravediggers we've
built 32 gravedigger trucks in the last
34 years
this is the dyno room my most favorite
place on the property 1500 horsepower
and we're gonna see a test pool right
now
yeah baby
trust me i have paid my dues all the way
down the line i have fractured my back
i've broke my shoulder i've broke my
ribs i've broke my nose a couple of
times i've broke my arms
when you talk about living a dream
that's this old guy right here
i never have grown up i still love toys
and that's why gravedigger is what it is
today
i think i've came up with the largest
collection of old american cars in the
world
yeah all of them has a story
but they kindly take their place in the
forest you know and
they're part of the forest
they grew up partially in the forest
my name is walter dean lewis i run and
operate in on oak car city usa
i was born and raised in a junkyard and
i like junk yards
this land was clear when i started
putting them in there
i wanted nature to take its course and
we just let it go wild
these cars come from other junkyards and
just individual people and they all wind
up here at oak car city
ford chevrolet's general motors they
land out there in the forest
rotting away
we build things out of rust out there
and it is a piece of art
i never had money
so if i wanted anything i'd have to
build it myself
i want other people to be able to do
that
my name is matthew mac and taggart i own
vader body kits
we have a unique design car
that looks like a million dollars and we
produce it so that the average person
can build it for an affordable price
the best way to call this is a re-body
you're making a new car at an existing
car
we're cutting everything off and what
we're left with is just bare bones the
motor the drive train the frame of the
car
so you have all of your dashboard intact
all of your engine intact l wiring it's
just the cosmetics that's been cut off
the car
my whole life i always fixed up my own
cars so then i decided i was gonna
design my own car that uh i can call my
own it doesn't look like anything else
i'm extremely excited that a car that i
designed the vader is going to be used
in the suicide squad movie
i had built a car for a customer on the
other coast of florida while it was
there the production company walked in
and they said that's great it's perfect
you know it looks like a million dollars
and then nobody's seen it before
i think that it ties into suicide squad
because it's threatening when it drives
down the road
it's an angular
open mouth angry car
seeing my own design on the big screen
is really exciting to me
the easiest way to put it is it's a
lottery ticket
i wanted to design a supercar
i can't draw
i have no design experience so i just
shaped it out of phone
and it took me a year and a half
seven days a week before i had a car
out of the mold
literally had nothing when i finished
this
whatever money i had
went into developing this it was pretty
much the biggest chance i've ever taken
and this one just it's people love the
car it couldn't have worked out better
you don't buy a delorean unless you want
attention like you don't want to be out
in a delorean if you're having a bad day
because everybody's honking at you and
giving you thumbs up it's almost like a
happiness mobile
even with like 20 other deloreans
parked around like what is the story
with this one
the first time i saw delorean was in a
science museum i want to say in 1983
they had a brand new delorean the car of
the future parked in the lobby of the
science museum it became my dream car
and i always always wanted to own one
but it always seemed like wanting to own
you know magnum pi's ferrari or the van
from the a team like something
impossible that would never happen
i wrote this novel ready player one the
protagonist is kind of obsessed with 80s
pop culture and he loves doc brown's
time machine but he decides to take doc
brown's time machine and then mash in
three more of his favorite 80s super
vehicles the ghostbusters ectomobile
ecto-1 hit from knight rider and then
buckrubanza is jet car
so it has both a flux capacitor for
traveling through time and an
oscillation overthruster for traveling
through solid matter
i never imagined that i would finish the
book or that i would be able to sell it
or that it would become a movie but all
those things happened and once i sold
the movie rights then i realized i could
i could actually buy a delorean finally
and then recreate the delorean from the
book it makes me a lot more interesting
at my book signings when i pull up in a
time machine and it's like a traveling
80s museum
this is my uh ipad that i use to control
my time circuits this operates the flex
capacitor but mostly it's just fun like
at the stop light i just pretend that
i'm
dropping oil like spy hunter and then i
also have kits a little consideration
would be a beginning and my light bar
when i need to clear traffic because i
need to get to you know the site of a
job and bust a class 5 full roaming
vapor i can't be sitting in traffic
i love people who love the things they
love so passionately that that's just
not enough for them to uh talk about it
it has to manifest itself in their lives
some way they have to build their own
time machine or they have to cosplay you
know their favorite character i'm that
kind of person and so the car is a way
for me to do that
there's sun
there's sand
there's speed
well hold on i'm getting ahead of myself
in 1947 a hundred miles east of la a
bunch of world war ii vets formed a car
club called the oilers taking their
model t fords hot rodding them up and
racing them in the mojave desert
eventually the men got old the cars
broke down and their brand of bare
knuckle drag racing all but stopped
until now
my name is mel stiltz i'm with the race
of gentlemen my name is bobby green i'm
with the racist gentleman
with the blessing of the oilers club
founders mel and bobby resurrected the
club rebranding it the race of gentlemen
what is the race of gentlemen it's a
vintage car race on the beach but
there's that other layer to it
the race of gentlemen is in a sense a
time travel event
we go to great lengths to make it feel
like you could be in a different time
era
and the rules of the race stay true to
the time period as well
the body engine and running gear must be
of a certain age and must be
american-made well there's definitely
something about america in cars
all those incredible cars that we
created
starting from let's say the 1910s
up until probably about the 60s we're so
different than anywhere else in the
world things today are made to last a
month the 1932 ford is made to last
forever
it's not just about the cars and the
bikes it's about the camaraderie and all
the things that go in
people are like oh this is so cool
because not only is it a race it's like
a scene it's like a set it's lost in
time
and for the race of gentlemen the love
of classic american cars transcends
generations you've got young kids that
want to have a more simple life and
build and make things and then you've
got you know the old generation we all
kind of celebrate that that time when
when we built and we did things with our
hands
the race of gentlemen is definitely
helping to keep the sport alive with the
new generation
so
you